[Musik]
sind gerichtsunterlagen aus diesem jahr
ein forensisches dna gutachten das
klären soll ob man den schweren
vorwürfen einer new yorker frau etwas
dran sein kann für donald trump könnte
das verfahren vor einem new yorker
gericht zum problem werden ich denke es
ist ein sehr großes problem
die anschuldigung ist dass er diese frau
in dem umkleideraum eines kaufhauses
vergewaltigt hat und sie behauptet dass
es auf ihrer kleidung dna gibt die zu
donald trump gehört
[Musik]
donald trump aber ist noch präsident der
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
genießt noch freiheit vor
strafverfolgung mehr als ein dutzend
verfahren auf bundes- und bundesstaaten
ebene gegen ihn liegen derzeit auf eis
es geht dabei von vergewaltigung des
geldwäsche und bankbetrug in der minute
in der donald trump das amt verlässt
verliert er seine privilegien und seine
immunität sein sofortiges problem wird
eine geschworenen jury in manhattan new
york city sein wo er wegen bank-
versicherungs- und steuerbetrug
angeklagt wird und wohl auch wegen
anderer verbrechen dass man hier in new
york für donald trump ein auge zudrückt
es praktisch ausgeschlossen
new york verachtet ihn zu viele offene
rechnung hat er hinterlassen und wenn es
um vergewaltigung und sexuelle nötigung
geht kennen new yorker gericht erst
recht kein pardon
das musste gerade erst der hollywood
mogul habe einst ihn erfahren auch
donald trump könnte vor einem großen
problem stehen wenn sich ihre vorwürfe
beweisen lassen journalistin jim carroll
behauptet donald trump habe sie mitte
der 90er jahre vergewaltigt der
präsident bestreitet
das ist eine total falsche anschuldigung
ich habe absolut keine ahnung wer diese
frau ist da gibt es ein foto auf dem es
so aussieht als würden wir uns die hand
geben auf irgendeiner veranstaltung
ich habe meinen mantel an und meine frau
steht neben mir
ich habe keine ahnung wer sie ist nicht
die geringste es ist eine falsche
anschuldigung eine sauerei jim carroll
aber will das nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen
die vergewaltigung ist zwar
strafrechtlich verjährt aber sie fühlt
sich vom präsidenten verleumdet und hat
ihn jetzt verklagt
im rahmen des verfahrens schildern ihre
anwälte den tathergang folgendermaßen
carroll und kramp treffen sich zufällig
in einem luxus kaufhaus man kennt sich
flüchtet doch noth ram sagt er wolle ein
geschenk für ein mädchen kaufen fragt ob
sie eine idee carroll schlägt eine
handtasche vor trump winkt ab bringt
reizwäsche ins spiel und bittet carroll
um anprobe als sie ablehnt packt er zu
drückt sie in einer abschließbaren
umkleidekabine an die wand und drückt
seine lippen auf ihren mund und dann
zitat
im nächsten moment er hatte noch seinen
anzug seine krawatte und seinen mantel
an öffnet er den mantel dann den
reißverschluss seiner hose hat mir in
meinen privaten bereich und schiebt
seinen penis halb oder ganz da bin ich
mir nicht sicher in mich hinein
carroll kramny zwischen die beine und
befreit sich zu hause erzählt sie einer
freundin was passiert ist und verwahrt
die kleidungsstücke so ihre schilder für
donald trump könnte genau das jetzt zum
problem werden sie hat die
kleidungsstücke behalten und gerichtlich
beantragt dass seine dna mit der auf
ihren kleidungsstücken verglichen wird
wenn die dna übereinstimmt dann wird es
viele verfahren von frauen geben die
behaupten dass er sie sexuell genötigt
hat ein forensisches gutachten hat alle
kleidungsstücke die kelle zum
tatzeitpunkt getragen hat auf dna-spuren
untersucht die forensiker sind zu dem
schluss gekommen dass sie an den
kleidungsstücken männliche dna einer
unbekannten person wissen
das gericht hat carol erlaubt eine
dna-probe von donald trump zu fordern
der weigert sich und verweist auf sein
amt diese strategie aber wird nicht mehr
aufgehen wenn er sein amt verloren hat
das gilt auch für ein
ermittlungsverfahren das die
staatsanwaltschaft new york unter
größter geheimhaltung gegen den tramp
konzern und dessen boss führt in einem
hearing vor dem us kongress hatte donald
trumps langjähriger mittlerweile
verurteilte anwalt schwere vorwürfe
gegen seinen ehemaligen chef erhoben
donald trump ist ein betrüger ich
übergebe dem komitee heute seine
bilanzen von 2011 bis 2013
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht dass herr
tram nach belieben sein vermögen auf
bläst wenn es ihm passt zum beispiel
wenn er auf der forbes reichenliste
erscheinen will es aber klein rechnet
wenn es darum geht steuern zu bezahlen
es geht um bank- versicherungs- und
steuerbetrug eine milliarde schuldete
präsident banken und unbekannten
kreditgebern
das hat das magazin fonds recherchiert
hunderte millionen werden in den
nächsten vier jahren fällig auch bei der
deutschen bank
der vorwurf der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft new york
manipulation seiner vermögensgüter um
sich bankkredite und
versicherungspolicen zu erschleichen
und sie werfen darüber hinaus trank der
trump organisation und
familienmitgliedern vor die bilanzen
manipuliert und gefälscht und
vermögensgüter unterbewertet zu haben um
steuern zu vermeiden und sie
überbewertet zu haben um bankkredite zu
bekommen
trump drohen schadensersatz und
strafzahlungen in dreistelliger
millionenhöhe
aber es ging für ihn um noch sehr viel
mehr meint werner delfmann ehemalige
ankläger der generalstaatsanwaltschaft
gefängnis ihm droht gefängnis
ich denke da an eine höchststrafe von
bis zu zehn jahren
zusammengenommen aus allen
anklagepunkten ich kann mir viele jahre
im gefängnis vorstellen das sei auch der
grund da sind sich viele beobachter
einig dass tornow trump seine
wahlniederlage bis heute nicht
anerkennen will
[Musik]
donald trump hat entsetzliche angst
davor ins gefängnis zu gehen wenn er
sein amt verlassen muss
das ist der grund warum er so
verzweifelt daran festhält
er weiß dass er viele gesetze gebrochen
hat und er weiß dass die leute dieses
mal ernsthaft hinter ihm her sind
und er scheint bereit zu sein seine über
70 millionen wähler weiter gegen einen
staat aufzuheizen der ihn ins gefängnis
bringen könnte